hey guys it is Thursday my name's Jeff
I'm Dan and you are watching GameSpot
news here's the things that have been
doing gaming today
[Music]
first up fans of the silver head son of
Spyder Dante will be glad to hear that
the Devil May Cry HD collection is on
its way to modern consoles Capcom has
revealed that the Devil May Cry HD
collection which was originally released
on ps3 and 360 back in 2012 will make
its way to ps4 Xbox one and PC in March
of next year
that's part of the package you'll get 60
frames per second HD versions of the
amazing Devil May Cry the kind of
alright Devil May Cry 2 and the amazing
again Devil May Cry 3 Dante's Awakening
they'll join the already available Devil
May Cry 4 and DMC Devil May Cry Capcom
also revealed any other details on what
improvements the new version may offer
over the previous release but as soon as
we know you'll know the devil may cry HD
Edition will be available both
physically and digitally for $30 UV soft
have been busy changing a bunch of
release dates ahead of tonight's game
Awards we also got our first update on
the progress of Beyond Good and Evil 2
first up those changed release dates far
cry 5 and the crew to have had their
release date shifted so Ubisoft can
invest more time in their development
open world first-person wallet simulator
USA Far Cry 5 has been moved from
February 27 2018 to March 27 2018 while
the crew tomb has been moved from the
concrete date of March 16th next year to
the first half of Ubisoft 2018 to 19
fiscal year which means it could be
released anytime between April to
September 1 other unannounced Ubisoft
franchise game has been moved to the
2019 to 20 fiscal year what could it be
my money's on milestones now to that
Beyond Good and Evil 2 news Ubisoft has
released a sort of unconventional
trailer detailing the progress Ubisoft
Montpellier have made seeing a creative
director Michelle and Cell describes
being focused on bringing the
motivations of plays to the game while a
senior producer wants to include the
complete pirate experience just with an
outerspace twist in the video we get to
look at some of the designs for ships
that are currently possible Unseld
acknowledged that the game is taking a
long time explaining we don't say no we
say yes to giant spaceships of bringing
lots of friends into the spaceship
online Adventures of the solo experience
also all these things are we say yes we
can make it we can connect all the
features together but no
he's ever made this kind of thing a
video game before so the pressure is
still on which is good if you're
interested you can sign up to the space
monkey program ubisoft's open design
initiative and give your feedback on the
game's progress directly to the
developers finally it's been revealed
that a new Tomb Raider game is on the
way although we don't know too much
about it just yet Square Enix confirmed
the news in a brief statement that
basically just says the game is on the
way it reads driven by our goal of
putting our fans first we want you to
know that it won't be long between the
official reveal and when you can play
our journey we'll begin with a major
event in 2018 we simply can't wait to
take you on Lara Croft's defining
adventure this does substantiate rumors
we've been hearing for years back in
2015 Square Enix bus Phil Rogers let
slip that a third title could be in the
pipeline while the name shadow of the
Tomb Raider was potentially leaked in a
PowerPoint presentation this year we
don't know who's developing the game or
what platforms it will arrive on just
yet but sit tight and we'll let you know
how this one progresses that's
everything we have for you today enjoy
the rest of your day and we'll be
covering everything from tonight's game
awards and everything from PlayStation
experience this weekend so make sure you
keep checking back to GameSpot and we'll
see you tomorrow for our biggest stories
of the week we're gonna have a chat
about them do join us then
you